[Music]
well hello dear friends we're so pleased
that you decided to join us today for
our question and answer program I'd like
to know you send us your questions we do
the research and then we do our best to
find the answer to your questions and we
put them on the air thank you for
joining us today uh if you want to send
us questions you'll see the address on
the screen uh TVM tv.org once again TVM
tv.org by the way I'm Steven bore
president of Secrets unsealed in some TV
and with me is Pastor David Salasar a
really good friend friend a man of many
talents uh we're very glad that he's
here at Secrets unsealed he adds not
only theological knowledge but also many
other gifts and we're glad to have you
with us thank you Pastor you're so kind
and I'm also blessed to be with you and
to learn and to share and study together
the word of God do we get along here at
secret sunseal I think we do no we do
for sure we get along well very well CA
always underlines this point oh you know
we get along so well and we really do
it's like a family amen anyway uh what
we want to do is have a word of prayer
because never should we open God's word
or answer questions without reference to
God's word and so I'm going to ask
Pastor Salasar if he would please pray
for us that God will give us wisdom
absolutely let us pray heavenly father
as we come before your throne of grace
we want to thank you for allowing us to
receive from you the gift of the Holy
Spirit that you promise to be sent to
those who ask and humbly ask to receive
that influence the power to understand
and to answer the the questions
according to your will and to your word
so I I pray now that you will be with me
and Pastor bour that we will be able to
answer the questions in a way that will
reach the hearts and bring people closer
to you and to the knowledge of the truth
I pray all of this in Jesus name amen
amen
well I understand that our first
question is uh quite sensitive yes um
and uh we are not going to read the
question because uh it might uh you know
reveal information to people who know
the
situation uh but we're going to give a
generic response so what is the question
that we have right pastor we have this
question in regards to a situation that
an
individual chose to embrace the
transgender lifestyle and has legally
changed the name from One gender to
another now the situation that the
family and those that uh love this
individual have uh you know are are
involved in right now is do
they embrace the change of name and call
these individual by the new gender and
the new name or do they stick to
the gender that was assigned or she
received in birth as as she was a
individual and is are they going to keep
that uh name that she had when was born
so this is the question and so we want
to know an answer according to the word
and to What the Lord Has revealed to us
what is truly the way that these family
should embrace this individual this
person well the bottom line is that we
have to go by what the Bible say says
mhm and the Bible clearly states that
God made two genders male and female mhm
there's not a single example in the
Bible of someone who was transgender now
uh
crossdressing is forbidden MH in the
levitical law yeah but there's no person
that we know of who uh embraced a
different gender than what they were
born you know the Bible tells us that
there are two gend genders male and
female so uh biologically when a person
is born their gender is determined by
birth the big question is what do the
relatives do with this person uh do they
use the the gender that the person
adopted uh even though they know it's
contrary to what the Bible teaches yeah
or uh do they uh make a decision that
they're going to call the person by the
gender that the person had at Birth MH
so that's the Dilemma how how do we
resolve this dilemma well Pastor you
know I believe that the example um in
regards to as you will mentioned the
Bible is very clear there's two genders
but you know we have to understand that
this situation is unique in the sense
that it's really in this day and age
that we are embracing these situations
these changes of gender but the
principle is the bottom line is that
this person is in transgression of God's
law it's choosing a lifestyle that goes
contrary to the word of God it's
something that God disapproves and has
never um approved of or or supported now
with that said the story that I think
will help us and see what are we to do
in response to the decision of somebody
to choose a lifestyle that contrary is a
story that we find in Luke 15 uh which
is a the story of the prodical son and
we know in the story uh just I'm going
to briefly just read a couple of verses
here of the story so we know what we are
to do it says there in uh chapter
15 verse 11 a certain man had two sons
and the younger of them said to his
father father give me the portion of the
goods that have fallen to me and he
divided unto them his living and not
many days after the younger son gathered
all together and took his journey into a
far country and there wasted his
substance with right righteous living
now this is a decision of somebody that
chooses to take the blessings of the
Lord and use them for themselves and for
gratifying their own Pleasures their own
desires their own inclinations he choses
to leave the Father the family that love
that individual because this is a family
who loves this individual cannot just go
along with that individual cannot say
okay you know what you're going to go in
that path like the sun I'm you're going
to go and live a life of frivilous life
I'm going to follow you no you cannot
break your principles trying to support
that individual and this is where I
think we have to be very careful that we
honor God and not man Even though with
there's Links of love and of course
affection or family but you have to
understand that there's a principle and
a line of Distinction that you cannot
cross just because that individual is
family or is a loved one and just like
in the story of the partical son we are
to remain steadfast on principle be
willing to love them and forgive them if
they choose to return and come back and
reject the lifestyle once it is now that
doesn't mean that you're not going to
accept it in the home you can but you
need to maintain yourself strong strong
and faithful to what God did with this
individual and call that individual by
the you know the name that was given at
Birth yeah this person who wants uh the
family to use the new gender pronouns M
um is a relative right and uh and so my
recommendation would be that uh you
stick with the gender that God gave the
person and show as much love as you can
be because it's a relative uh the
relative is going to know that that
these individuals who sent us the
question they are Bible oriented yeah in
other words they abide by what the Bible
says mhm and so they are going to use uh
the biblical pronoun they're going to
use uh the male or the female name yeah
depending on whether it's a male or a
female right um and and try and be as
nice as possible yeah um you know you
love The Sinner mhm but you hate the sin
and some people say now Pastor how's it
possible to love The Sinner and hate the
sin if the sinner committed the sin well
I was on a talk show one time in New
Jersey and the moderator uh I don't know
how we got into this discussion but I
said you know that God loves a sinner
but he hates the sin and he says so
how's that possible this was a secular
guy that's not possible he says so I
said let me ask you a
question uh do you have children so of
course I have children I said do your
kids ever do anything that really makes
you
mad we all have children know that if
they do he says yes so I said do you
hate them because of what they
did no do you still love them of course
you hate what they do but you don't hate
them you love them so in this case I
would suggest that the family who sent
us the question yeah you know they use
the genders uh in which the person was
born but let them know that they love
this person and this person knows what
their principles are undoubtedly because
they're family uh it's a difficult
situation but we need to stick by the
Bible and not by what culture dictates
and there is always the danger and I
because I've heard of other examples
similar to this and is it's not
necessarily just about this situation
but whether it's drugs or addiction to
certain things that are really you know
destroying the life or taking them away
from the Lord but you know some people
say well but the thing is if if I if I
act this way by principle I will
lose seeing them or having them here
they're not going to be you know happy
they're not going to want to come to my
house they don't want to be around me
and we have to learn understand and this
is why the prodical son gives this
example you know why did he leave
because he didn't feel comfortable in
the household where the father honored
God and he didn't want to hear you know
the the constant saying look you're not
to do this you're not to do this you
know these things so he said you know
what I'm leing and sometimes you have to
let people go their way follow their own
path until they come to the point when
they realize that sin only destroys them
themselves that sin separates them from
true happiness and true peace and so
it's not that you want them you know
something bad to happen to them but you
have to be willing to stand firm in
principle loving them AB absolutely but
stand firm in principle and if they
choose to leave continue to pray for
them find ways to reach out to them but
not Embrace or support their lifestyle
you know there's something that's not in
the story of The Prodigal Son and that
is um where the father have been okay
with a prodigal staying at home and
having the harlots come into the house
and uh you know have these parties uh
with all of his friends and uh waste all
of his father's money while living in
the house I don't think so no he the
father said okay you're tired of the
rules and regulations of the house you
know I love you I would hope that you
that you don't go down this path but you
have freedom of choice if you leave I'm
going to love you
and of course when hard times came the
love of the father Drew him back yeah so
I think that's a very good story to
illustrate uh maybe how this situation
should be faced amen yes Pastor I think
that's the only to me that's the way to
to answer this question because it's a
difficult and we have to ask you know
remind our friends to to really ask the
Lord for wisdom and guidance and to
remain firm to the Lord and be you know
faithful to him after all it is going to
separate you know Christ said Ma I came
to put you know a sword between certain
individuals even family parents and Sons
and this is the truth sometimes truth
they separates but eventually the Lord
will I mean continue to work he will
never stop working in bringing back to
this individual the need to return to
him so bottom line the principle is we
must obey God rather than man amen amen
all right well we have another question
that comes from um uh Florida oo Florida
and where so so thankful that uh you
know the Lord has helped this state that
suffered a lot recent you know with the
many hurricanes during this past uh
Autumn but let's look at this question
he says hello pastors thank you for your
dedication in answering the diverse
range of questions your program receives
in a clear and concise manner always
based on the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy my wife and I enjoy watching
the program regularly I would like to
ask if the crowns Stephanos in Greek of
gold that the 24 Elders from from
Revelation 4:4 half on their heads could
belong to in harmony with Pastor B's
eloquent the 24 Elder series powerful
angels of or the highest angels to whom
God has delegated the responsibility of
ruling over the unfallen worlds who have
also gained victory over sin I added who
have also gained victory over sin
because in early writings page
393 sister G relates that she was given
a view of other world and that an angel
attended her to a place that was bright
and glorious in this place she she saw
two trees and the inhabitants had the
power to eat of both but were forbidden
to eat of one then the angel said to her
none in this place have tasted of the
Forbidden tree but if they should eat
they would fall since one of the
inhabitants had also previously
indicated to Sister white white that
they had lived in strict obedience to
the Commandments of God and have not
fall Fallen by Disobedience like those
on the earth could this be a considered
or could this be considered as having
gained victory over seene and therefore
being able to wear a Stefanos on their
head thank you so much Wilson Perez from
AO Florida and um I mentioned him
because then he put a PS This is a side
note and something that is really
amazing my wife had a singing part and I
accompanied her on the piano at Pastor
David salar's and julissa's wedding in
Orlando Florida my father was also from
Kito Ecuador so this is a amazing uh
memory that um happened several years
ago but I'm so thankful that he watches
the programs and it's it's wonderful to
see I hope that we can get in touch with
him again and and reconnect he's been
many years since we last saw him you
know it's very interesting that uh I
don't remember much about my
wedding who sang I know that my dad had
the sermon at house but that's about it
because your your mind is totally fried
from all the preparations and also from
being concentrate concentrating yeah on
the wedding itself yes absolutely Pastor
you're absolutely right I I have a a
hard time remembering every single part
because I was very nervous so as you can
imagine but so thankful anyway so this
question Pastor from a friend uh Wilson
Paris uh is asking about you know this
position you think it's I mean is he the
right I don't know idea with this
concept okay basically um just to
synthesize his point M um I mentioned
that uh the 24 Elders are the
representatives of the worlds that never
sinned yeah and that they have
crowns and some people say well nowhere
in the Bible do you find that angels
have crowns but Ellen White repeatedly
mentions that angels have crowns so the
the idea is that the word Stephanos
there's two words for Crown one is
diadema uh it's used in Revelation 19
when Jesus comes as king of kings and
Lord of lords right and then you have
the word Stephanos where my name comes
from uh Stephen uh and and that word
supposedly always means the crown of a
Victor now it's interesting the solution
that uh that this brother brother Wilson
is given to the situation I hadn't
thought about this before before I read
question that you know beings of other
worlds uh they there's a tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil in those
worlds yeah and they never gave into sin
they gained the victory in other words
yeah so the the person who represents
that world would wear a stepanos because
he never ate from the tree and never
committed sin right that's an
interesting way of doing it yeah uh but
there's another way also and I bring
this out in my study notes on the 24
Elders mhm
um the idea is that um the word stepanos
always means the Victor's Crown and
diadema is the king's crown but not
always uh in secular both in secular
literature uh the word stepanos can be
used simply for um for someone you know
who's a king uh let me just give you two
examples from the New Testament um one
uh those examples is the crown that
Jesus wore oh yeah it's in Matthew 27:29
that's a Stephanos M it says when they
had Twisted a crown of thorns they put
it on his head and a reed in his right
hand and they bowed the knee before him
and mocked him saying hail King of the
Jews now they were not putting a
stepanos on him to say that he's uh
Victorious no of course not because that
he was be being defeated in their minds
um you know if they believe that uh that
he was uh claiming to be a a reigning
King it seems like they would have put a
diadema yeah on his head instead of a
stepanos uh there's another reference in
Revelation
14:14 where it speaks about the end of
the investigative judgment before Jesus
comes as king yeah and it says then I
looked and behold a white cloud and on
the cloud set one like the son of man
having on his head a Golden Crown of
stepanos and in his hand a sharp sickle
mhm um this this verse is frequently
applied to the second coming but really
it's applying to the close of probation
because Ellen White States in Christ
object lessons that the that the Harvest
is the close of probationary time and so
when probation closes uh it says here
that he is wear wearing a stepanos but
he has not been crowned yet as a king
with the diadema and so there are
exceptions where the word stepanos is
used for uh for a king not necessarily
somebody who has gained the victory over
sin thank you so so there are two
different ways of approaching this that
shows that uh that really uh the 24
Elders can be representatives of the
worlds and they can still wear crowns
let me just uh mention here
um Ellen White says that when man sinned
in the garden angels cast their crowns
from their heads when he suffered in
Gethsemane they cast their crowns to the
ground When Jesus ascended to Heaven it
says that they cast their glittering
glittering crowns before his feet when
probation closes it says the Angelic
host lays laid off their crowns and at
the second coming it says that the
angels that that accompany Jesus have
glittering crowns upon their heads so
very very frequently angels have crowns
now of course you don't know if Ellen
White is using diadema or she's using
stepanos because it's a different
language right but I think that the
evidence is quite persuasive thank you
Pastor I think this is very very clear
and and I pray that um you know our
friend continues to study I love the
fact that he's learning and and studying
and comparing scripture so that's really
important and thank you for that Insight
or that way of looking at that we might
have time for just one more question
that is again sensitive but I think the
answer can be given to this individual
this person I won't read the the
question is rather long but uh the
sentences of this of the question is in
regards to someone who
has
married left the individual committ
adultery had to be divorced then married
again and uh this time you know tried to
do better but again fell into sin and uh
when through a process of even re
rebaptism in the church what not but
still didn't work with the marriage
separated had to he that person asked to
be removed from the books of the church
and married again for the third time and
this time he's committed to the to the
to the Lord committed to the marriage
but the spouse the the wife is not uh
seems not to be committed to the Lord
from what we gathered so the question is
this pastor what can these individual do
that should these individual you know
separate a third time or should remain
married with someone that is not
committed to the Lord my first counsel
would be be careful who you marry yeah
and uh you know stay close to the Lord
so you're faithful yeah to your partner
uh it sounds like U the the spouse is
not 100% guilty it always goes both ways
MH uh but but really
um the Bible is clear
that the only reason for divorce and
remarriage is in the case of someone
that commits adultery right so um in
this case there have been three
marriages and what he's asking is should
I separate now in my third
marriage and it would be far better to
struggle and save the marriage yeah you
know don't give up uh you know if if
your wife says you know you need to
change ask the Lord for grace and power
to change MH um so you know if you get
separated after a third
marriage maybe there'll be a fourth
right you know so so really you need to
make up your mind that you're going to
be faithful to your wife from this point
on and through your faithfulness to the
Lord if that spouse that you have is not
converted is not committed to the Lord
uh there is that text also that your
faithfulness your love showing your love
of the Lord to that individual might be
the way to gain that individual to love
the Lord and come to the Lord so I think
it's important that that individual
remains as just mentioned Pastor
committed to Christ to the Lord and also
of course to your to the spouse to the
wife and and and try to show the love of
God in their marriage showing the
character of the Lord through her his
actions towards her yeah so I think that
uh the person uh who sent us this
question has manifested quite a bit of
guilt in what he said so so there's a
good there's a good attitude there yes
that there needs to be a change in what
he has done in the past right and the
Lord forgives the grace of God is ample
to forgive amen but don't continue
making the same mistake all over again
amen praise the Lord okay well our time
is up thank you so much for joining us
uh at our program I'd like to know hope
to see you next time when we will answer
answer further questions God bless you
[Music]